since taking the white house six months
ago the bib administration has
from the very beginning used immigration
to change the demographic mix
of our country not to improve the
country or the lives of people who come
here
but to flood the united states with
loyal new democratic voters so that
america becomes a one-party state in
perpetuity
this is their version of democracy or if
you don't like the outcome you just
change the electorate that's true
you're absolutely not allowed to
acknowledge this is happening if you do
they will scream that you're a
conspiracy nut you're a bigot you must
be silenced forever
left the hard way a couple of months ago
the great
replacement theory it's a lie they yell
george soros has nothing to do with that
stop
talking but because the people who make
the rules can say whatever they feel
like saying the very same democrats who
yell at you
if you mention this brag in public about
the great replacement they acknowledge
that it's real and they love it
here's the dwarfish dick durbin of
illinois doing just that
today on the senate floor watch this the
demographics of america are not on the
side of the republican party
the new voters in this country are
moving away from them
away from donald trump away from their
party
creed that they preach and instead
they're moving to be independents or to
even vote on the other side
oh so we want total control so we're
changing who lives
here they're not embarrassed at all
they're bragging about it
but they're still hiding most of the
details no reason to spook the quickly
shrinking pool of people who are born
here it's fine relax
last week we told you about a human
smuggling operation the biden white
house has been running out of laughlin
air force base in texas
the goal of the operation is to resettle
illegal immigrants throughout the
country throughout the interior
without the knowledge or permission of
the people who live in those places
otherwise known as the public the voters
they can't know
we got a tip that this was happening so
we called both the pentagon and
ice and they were forced to confirm that
it is happening the question we couldn't
answer is where are all these foreign
nationals going where they're being
flown
well tonight we have some indication of
that according to air traffic records
a 737 operated by a charter airline
departed laflin air force base last week
it headed to the former england air
force base in alexandria louisiana the
people who live there now
where did it go from there where all the
people on the plane go we don't have the
answer to that
we've also by the way obtained video of
a civilian plane using laughlin air
force base in texas the footage on the
screen right now
was taken by a local man called frank
lopez jr
so it's definitely happening we did not
make it up
the question is what are republicans in
the congress doing to stop it
well as it turns out the republican
represents del rio texas in the congress
tony gonzalez
is the very person who petitioned ice to
use laughlin air force base in the first
place to move foreign citizens to the
rest of the country
we know that because he put out a press
release about it on june 5th
gonzalez asked the acting assistant
secretary of the air force for
installations
someone called jennifer miller to use
the runways at laflin air force base
quote to fly migrants to their final
destination rather than releasing them
in the del rio
area congressman gonzalez added this
quote by utilizing laflin air force base
ice could address the high number of
migrant releases
and alleviate the pressure this crisis
has inflicted on border communities
end quote in other words tony gonzalez
doesn't want to deal with illegal
immigrants in large numbers in his
community and that's totally
understandable very few communities
want that they've never asked for it no
one's ever voted for this because nobody
actually wants it
what's harder to understand is why
gonzalez and a lot of other members of
the republican party
aren't trying to protect the rest of the
united states and stop this mass
outbreak of lawlessness an outbreak by
the way that's about to get a lot worse
very soon a senior administration
official has confirmed to joe simonson
of the washington free beacon
that a new flood of illegal migrants
from around the world is on
the way the official said the white
house is about to suspend
title 42 that's a regulation that's been
used by the cdc to block migrants from
entering this country
on public health grounds like during a
pandemic for example
turns out kovid isn't a big deal when
foreigners have it and bring it to this
country it's fine and you're a racist if
you think otherwise
so they're repealing the rule once that
happens the administration expects an
even bigger wave on our border and then
at some point in your neighborhood
because they'll be flown at your expense
there
do republicans know this of course they
do do they care
that's an open question hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else